um you obviously have been somebody who
tapped in with this what's going on in
Stockton because Stockton's kind of on
fire right now man
kind of the base cousin a little bit you
know yeah yeah a lot of people who
aren't from the bay lump Sacramento
Stockton and the bay all is one even
though they're not I don't know
um you worked with young slobby before
he passed away talk about your guys's
relationship obviously rest in peace to
him but you know that was a big loss for
Stockton RP my [__] Mary since I tapped
in with him like even because he just
been genuine for as my [__] like I call
that [__] like we just talk on some
other [__] not even on no music [__] for
real like he'll come pull up on me you
feel me uh I I line little plays up from
for him to go get this so you send me
all type of little [__] as my [__]
RP that [__] man I [__] well I really
[__] with mostly I [__] with a lot of
ebk [__] though I ain't gonna lie I
[__] with Jack I [__] with Jay bro
Trey B little my ballet I [__] with a
lot of them [__] [__] cool do you
ever do like shows in Stockton uh I did
it so in Stockton before probably like
an SOB shot
I probably did a solo show like not too
long ago but that'd be so much [__]
going on I wouldn't even remember you've
been a part of some crazy [__] man for
sure I probably the last time I'll
probably do this on Stockton probably
like a year or two ago I don't remember
being out there but I know a [__] did a
couple shows out there for sure yo what
was it like being a part of the Black
Panther soundtrack
because that kind of was a moment yeah
Kendrick was on that record too yeah
that's a big deal now first of all not a
lot of people these days sharing records
with Kendrick and that's one of the
biggest movies of all time so that's my
biggest song to this day that
[__] went like double platinum
in that mother for just a song that
selling it ain't got no videos no video
nothing I feel like that was kind of
like the last hurray for SOB kinda yeah
that was like our biggest I feel like
after that [__] is when [__] kind of
started uh yeah man a lot of [__]
started happening man behind the scenes
you know how that [__] go man just some
old brother [__] though [__] fighting
behind the scenes like we brothers and
we was young you know how that [__] go
like but what was that moment like for
you like just kind of knowing you met
you're making it onto a Marvel movie
soundtrack and and Kendrick's hopping on
the record I ain't gonna lie when we
first got in the studio we got on that
[__] like
I really ain't think it was gonna really
come out he's like yep we at least got
the chance to be in the studio with that
[__] and give us what oh you guys are
in the studio with him hey we got the so
[__] really just had the mindset like
[__] at least we got up in the studio
and got the chance to defend me show
that [__] what we got for real you fan
and it's a banger but when that [__]
came out
I heard the uh Black Panther [__] came
out but [__] Ain't really think you
sent me our [__] was on there so I
really didn't even check like
[__] was just calling a [__]
like yo you made the Black Panther
soundtrack y'all [__] going crazy
[__] your first one stupid I'm like
hell nah I'm in the studio at the time
too recording I go straight to the
soundtrack I listen to that [__] the way
he put the little pause on my [__] I was
like oh I ain't gonna lie like that [__]
then they're like gave a [__]
Goosebumps right you feel me the way
that that [__] hit a [__] with the the
boy you feel me then changed the tempo
for like four bars like I ain't gonna
lie that [__] had a [__] feeling like a
champion you know like when you growing
up a [__] got you you in sports you
wanted trophies and [__] when I was
playing sports like online really win
too many trophies right like I was
really a Streetball player I wouldn't
really you found me one of the ones
really really on the court so you family
[__] like that like that's a trophy for
me